a lot of people are very bad at time
management I had this kid at the airport
like you spit all this stuff I ain't got
time I'm like take out your phone he's
like all right I'm like show me your
calendar he's like no I'm like show me
your [__] calendar takes out his
calendar dude's got three meetings I do
78 meetings a day 15 minutes because 30
minute meetings are really 15 and 1 hour
meetings are really 30 if you're doing a
2hour lunch meeting you got time
attention is the number one asset let's
rock hello how are you my name's ismel
Isel great pleasure
so I have a question for you about nfts
please where do you see that going in
the next 3 to 5 years 3 to five so I had
you been following the space for a while
a little bit Yeah so thank God and I
felt it in August of 2020 thank God I
started making all those videos that 99%
of these things were going to zero CU if
I didn't I'd be in a very different
place with my brand I if if you remember
those videos I put out a year and a half
ago the reason I thought this was going
to happen was was cuz it just became
about greed and that's what I saw with
the internet stocks in 1997 to give you
a history lesson cuz there's a lot of
youngsters in here the first wave of
Internet stocks in 1997 89 we had
companies like pets.com be worth like $5
billion but hadn't even sold anything
yet it was just early internet and the
internet was right is right but those
companies were overvalued the reason I
said 99% were going to go to zero is
nfts are right first of all nfts are a
major technology it's not just
Collectibles it's where all of you are
going to by the way especially for this
industry all the Deeds all the mortgages
all the leases they're going to be on
the blockchain there's no reason for it
to sit in a municipality where the [__]
can burn down like in the next decade
especially with AI and deep fake videos
this world is going to start
understanding why the blockchain's a big
deal but what we just had the last two
years was complete speculation
Ridiculousness that and listen you all
know this we see that in real estate
estate we see that in trading cards we
see that in art you have these Ze and
flows but where do I see it I see it I
see it similar to the internet I think
the blockchain will be one of the most
profound Technologies I think nf's
definition will broaden into many things
and just like trading cards 99% of
trading cards bro are worthless but
Michael Jordan rookie cards are valuable
99% of sneakers are not collectible but
stockx does trillions on the ones that
are 99% of art is garbage 99% of watches
are not worth [__] so that's where
everybody gets caught up they're like
all of nfts nah they were confused they
didn't want to hear it people were
talking from a place of greed and so for
me it was exciting because I always
wanted to buy like an old IP like Smurfs
or Scooby-Doo or like the Care Bears I
always wanted to buy one and refurbish
it it allowed me to do my Pokemon meet
Sesame Street V friends and I love the
space but it's going to need 3 to four
years to get the stigma off of what just
happened and the technology will grow
and then I think it'll be
meaningful pleasure of course my man
thank
you hey Gary good to see you again you
were talking earlier about essentially
marketing versus selling and how people
branding versus sales both matter right
but but when people do branding and
marketing they actually are trying to
say I need to sell and they don't
realize it which then why it's all
confusing for everyone correct so in the
podcast episode you and I did we talked
a little bit about this but for
especially an audience of large Mortgage
in real estate for people that don't
necessarily have money to invest in help
and they're out there trying to sell and
get the transaction can you go a little
bit deeper on how to balance the two
because as you said a lot of us bought
clothes and items based more on brand
than the actual call to action sales for
the smaller business or for the
individual profession professional how
do you unpack that look that was the
first eight years of my life just to you
know going to the reverse of what I just
told you earlier before there were 29
employees on my content I did eight and
a half years all by
myself so what what do I think everyone
should do that I think that a lot of
people are very bad at time management
they tell me I had this kid at the
airport's like yo I hear all your
[__] spit great kid I like them like
that's why I chopped with them like you
spit all this stuff he's like I ain't
got time I'm like take out your phone
he's like all right I'm like show me
your calendar he's like no I'm like show
me your [__] calendar takes out his
calendar dude's got three meetings bro
do you know what my you know what my
calendar looks like I do 78 meetings a
day 15 minutes because 30 me minute
meetings are really 15 and 1 hour
meetings are really 30 if you're doing a
2hour lunch meeting you got
time so what do I think I think people
need to make content and I gave them
permission today you know you know I
know you know my stuff I'm starting to
really because I'm writing J you know
the new book like you don't want to be
on camera because you're a little you
cuz people beat themselves up visually
like I really believe in that everyone's
beautiful thing I understand some people
are universally considered attractive
versus not but like the thought that are
people are here are not going to build
their actual business and dream because
they're scared of one person saying
they're ugly in a comment on Instagram
breaks my heart let me just talk on that
real quick cuz I know this [__] stops
y'all if somebody takes the time out of
their day to go around the internet to
find you and tell you that you're ugly
or stupid think about how sad their
[__] life
is stop feeling bad for you when people
say that to you start feeling bad for
them so I I think people should do what
I started doing 15 years ago I believe
everyone here should make content
I believe it is absolutely enormous not
to mention even if they never hit it in
Social it's them practicing their sales
pitch it's them engaging with people a
lot of you are trying to get to people
let me give you an example of a real
estate or a mortgage professional that
is all day long one of the most clever
moves everyone can do here you start a
podcast around the town you do business
in and now you're reaching out to people
that you want to do business with and
instead of trying to sell to them you
tell the rich dentist in your town hey
you're a pretty amazing dentist you want
to be on my podcast to tell people about
your Dentistry now you've just turned a
sales
pitch and not into a sales pitch but now
you're giving the dentist a platform now
that dude's coming to your [__] house
now you're [__] friends now you get
their [__]
business that's a good
idea and by the way let me tell you
about humans they've all got egos even
though nobody's listening to your
podcast nobody asked that dentist to
ever be on a podcast before and he's
[__]
pumped my man hey Gary Spencer here
Spencer as a DTC eCommerce brand yes at
kind of a impulse purchase price point
how much um 30 to $50 nice that's
something brand like it okay so as that
brand what paid advertising platform
would you target before other if you
were just
ch Facebook number one which is crazy
right but like the way you ask the
question right like I only have so much
money like your biggest upsite is
probably Tik Tok but Tik Tok ad product
is not as refined as Facebook right now
for DTC and there's enough vulnerability
there that I'm not sure you know how to
make the content for Tik Tok What what
made everybody win in DTC with Facebook
is you didn't have to to make good
content Facebook was so [__]
effective the math worked for everyone
they didn't realize they were doing
crappy ads it just worked cu the media
was so goddamn underpriced and people
like big companies would rather do a
million dollars doing TV commercial that
none of you would watch then put into
Facebook and that's where the ARB was so
I still think it's Facebook believe it
or not but I would say that if you feel
in your heart or your stomach you
understand what I'm saying about like
make content for the platform and you
understand the kind of content that
could work on Tik Tok and I would also
say here's a real good hack for all of
you selling something in that range post
like crazy
organically and when something goes
viral turn that creative into an ad I
call that brand formance you're doing
brand but the second the world told you
like I like this video you retake it and
you turn it into an you know you almost
turn it into QVC not a TV show like you
tweak it a little bit with a call to
action and hard right hitting like bye
bye bye and that will do extremely well
yeah we've got some content on Tik Tok
that's doing well organic so that's why
I was hearing towards that that Meta
Meta ads Crush that platform's so
[__] Advanced and Facebook
specifically because you have a older
demo that has a higher propensity to
buy but Tik Tok the ads the videos that
have gone well take them out again tweak
them with a call to action put a over
like it's okay to turn it into an ad and
rerun it as an ad I think you'll be
surprised thank you you got it
appreciate
it who do we got all right right here my
man how you doing my man I'm good bro
hey um so when you were talking about
doing six to 10 whatever posts per day
yeah is there a ramp up that you
recommend right going from zero to 100
is that are you like just go for 100% %
I'm trying to show an ideological like
an ideal space but bro if you do one
versus zero a day I'm
thrilled that's the sweet spot but
you'll this is why I use the physical
thing like you do 10 push-ups a day
you're going to get 10 push-up A Day
Results you do a 100 you're going to get
100 I mean like this is what's so fun
about being in this
game it's like oh damn like this is one
of the most Merit based like the reason
I love sports is you can hide almost
everywhere in life even entrepreneurship
I got friends who've had three
failed businesses and they suck [__] at
entrepreneurship but if you look at
their Instagram you think they're the
[__] greatest of all time but Sports
You Can't Hide you play oneon-one and
you lose 113 you lost
113 what I really like about social you
can sit here and say people got lucky
but it's not true people like Gary I've
been shadowbanned I'm like you haven't
been shadowbanned you just
suck
so yeah bro like to your point going Z
to 100's hard but but let me tell you
how I think about it if you go and film
something for an hour whatever it is a
day at work um a you know why is Dustin
here right now I would tell you that I
probably still public speak for the
content more than the
speech that the filming of this is
incredibly valuable for me because I'm
going to get six to seven I mean how
many people he follow me pretty well
just to give me a sense that's super
humbling thank you so y'all know I don't
make content I just film my life I'm too
busy to film content I'm not an
influencer I run businesses I have 4,000
employees with all the businesses
combined like when people come to Vayner
media they're like What's this like most
people think I'm like a motivational
speaker I'm like I'm a [__] operator
dick like so I figured out cuz I knew it
was so valuable okay wait a minute if I
film my every day that's how I'll get my
content cuzz I ain't got time to like
sit behind a green screen or you know
but most people do and you don't think
there's too much bro nobody's going to
see your [__] no
Overkill no I don't think there's too
much you're going to post tomorrow and
nine people are going to see it there's
8 billion people on
earth right but let's say let's say you
got LinkedIn or whatever platform serves
up to people who interact engage with
your stuff right there's never too much
of a good thing to your point so as long
as the content is quality right this
goes back to the Merit when I popped out
in like 2006 78 most people actually
thought I'd be gone in a year debating
on like who was going to win cuz I'm too
much I'm a lot and people thought okay
this is all sizzle the reason I'm still
here is I have it enough to say I'm good
enough by the way the reason I still
operate is the day you stop operating
you're out of touch the reason I'm
contempor good is because I'm actually
doing it and then I just talk about what
I'm doing it's really hard to talk about
Tik Tok properly if you've never done
Tik
Tok so no I don't think there's too much
brother I I look if you're and remember
when I say four or five times a day six
times a day I think you need to be on
seven platforms so it's not six on
LinkedIn the problem with most people
here is they're one-dimensional and just
on Instagram I'm talking about Twitter x
Facebook and then inside of it there's
now you got me it's Facebook and
Facebook reals it's Instagram and
Instagram stories it's Pinterest tons of
people here should be doing stuff on
Pinterest not even thinking about it
linkedin's a monster for everyone here
Facebook's still a monster YouTube
shorts is a monster YouTube long for
Monster like there's a lot going on out
here so that my
man go ahead my man Brandon zra how are
you I'm doing well put your mic to your
can you hear me now we're good uh just
something Jamie and I actually talk
about quite a bit is just your time
management cuz I know you're running
bajillion companies you still have a
social life you're still losing to your
brother in golf I was just curious like
what advice do you have and whatnot for
managing all these different companies
in a given day or month couple things on
the record regardless of what AJ told
you I've only played golf like 7even
times though he's beating me every time
because I've only played seven times
um I touched on it earlier my brother so
first of all I have three full-time
assistants and Two Chiefs of Staff five
human beings whose full life is to
manage every one of my minutes
but again because I just did it with
content the first 11
1998 the first 13 years of my career I
managed it
myself and what I learned when I managed
it myself was the number one thing I'm
positive of I'll die on this hill every
one of you spend too much time in
meetings that mean
nothing and so the time management to me
is the obsession with it being valuable
CU I'm hungry but I don't judge like I
want to take a big step
back if you're sitting here and you're
good you're good emotionally and you're
good
financially besides protecting your moat
that's working for you I don't care if
you do anything I'm
saying but if you're looking to grow you
just realize time is the one thing and I
think people don't invest in time
there's a lot of people here who are
doing pretty well and still don't have a
full-time admin because they think of it
as a cost and don't realize they'll
double their
salary right they're like [__] I don't
want to give up 70k for that or they're
too private my dad doesn't have an admin
because he was born in Russia and he
doesn't want anybody to know his
[__] meanwhile the last seven assistants
I've had can memorize like literally can
rattle off my social security number
right now for you so like we're really
the two extremes that everyone here is
in between but the the way I think about
it what I do is like I I put money into
capable people
to make it go well and then I refine it
and refine it and refine it I'll give
you a couple other tactics that might
might help people here how many people
here have an
admin so one big thing is how often I
meet with my admin Team every Thursday
for an hour or 30 minutes to look at the
week ahead and even though like on
Monday I'm like this is the most
important meeting book it next week for
an hour literally by Thursday when we do
it I'm like cancel that meeting because
shit's moving and things change and so
again it's kind of like that chicken and
egg game I don't think people are
committing enough dollars and time to
manage their time and that's how I
that's how I do it and then back to your
point VOR sports with AJ you know my
pickle ball team that I own like the
Esports team that I own like Vayner X
has 11 or eight companies in it V
friends the other thing is I put family
in charge of my businesses whether it's
my actual family like my brother AJ or
my family like Andy who's been with me
for 11 years and he runs V friends the
the if people are going to go to a real
high level and I hope all of you do if
that's what you want please remember
that adage of like don't bring friends
and family into the business is just as
wrong as nice guys finish last it is
dangerous and you could if you if you
care more about your money than your
best friend or your sister well then
You're vulnerable but if you don't and
you understand that [__] is [__]
compared to that relationship then you
should only surround yourself with
family and best friends it's the best
it's the
best but most people are scared to do it
because they have a belief and listen I
I have no interest in judging I'm just
sharing [__] that I see and not just my
own life I get to look at a lot of
businesses and I'm I'm older now I'm
grown I've seen it I'm so fortunate I'm
not attached to my money I'm not
attached to my notoriety I don't have my
selfworth wrapped up into Gary ve or my
bank account I have it to like who I am
as a dude so I got lucky I know that's
not everyone but if that's not you if
like you need that blue check mark if
you need that million followers if you
need that million dollars that's
something you should really work on
because you'll always be vulnerable if
that's true that means you value other
people's
opinion more than your own opinion about
your own
self let's keep it going this is all I
want to do oh [__] one more that's it
[__] all right one
more where are we going who's got it uh
hi Gary uh I'm Max elen and I'm 17 which
is like practically a kid and I just
want to ask not practically bro like
super [__] kid uh I just want to ask
you if uh you were now and you wanted to
tell yourself your younger 17-year-old
self a quote what would it be I would
tell the 17-year-old kid kid I'll talk
to you as if I'm talking to myself at 17
bro you got really lucky in the DNA game
your mom and dad had sex at the right
second and a lot of things went well for
you you stunningly got a ton of [__]
figured out but you have one major
problem your lack of cander to people
that you love is going to [__] you up
it's going to be your
cryptonite and so work on that and start
telling people how you actually feel and
that will really help you even if it
might hurt their micro feelings you
won't build resentment and it won't [__]
up your game besides that keep doing
what you've been doing which is and this
is now the advice I'm given you Max
brother listen to me at 17 the biggest
mistake that every 17-year-old makes on
Earth is they think they're supposed
to that's where I end it you think
you're supposed to based on your family
based on what content you consume based
on your life you think you're supposed
to X you think you're supposed to Y
right now with the way the world is some
17-year-olds live in families where they
think they're supposed to not go to
college and be an entrepreneur cuz their
folks are but maybe you [__] love
going to school that way and that's your
path and you fear being an entrepreneur
because you've seen your parents
struggle with
entrepreneurship more likely you think
you're supposed to do this college thing
or be a this or be a that or you want to
be an influencer or you're supposed to
be a lawyer bro at 17 what you need to
realize is how lucky you are how many
people here would give it all up to be
17 Again raise your hand
one more time because I want this kid to
have a moment this is a room of some by
the way I don't know if you saw how fast
my [__] hand went up how many people
in this room no [__] would give it
all up to be 17 Again raise your
hands brother listen to me for the you
could literally do nothing right for the
next 13 years of your life actually let
me say it a different way you could
literally do nothing right for the next
17 years of your life do you know what I
was doing professionally at 34 years old
old what I worked in my father's liquor
store I haven't even started what I am
now today to everyone here you have such
a scary amount of time what would I tell
you to do to like take a step back and
really think about what you like like
what you watch gaming
music rock climbing I don't [__] know
you you know what I mean but whatever it
is you have so much time to actually go
chase it live humbly though don't have
your parents or grandparents support
your dream if you have a dream and you
want to live it then [__] live on the
floor with your buddies right don't
become entitled and have somebody pay
for your dream but if you have a dream
go try to go after it for six seven 10
years and after 10 years 12 years 17
years then you could be like all right
look I went after it when I'm 80 I'll
never regret I want it to be this you
got to be self-aware you can't look at
yourself I I couldn't look at myself and
be like I want to be in the NBA that's
delusional yeah you know you have to you
can't be
delusional but you can absolutely
[__] do anything and none of it if it
goes wrong will matter other than you
need to make sure you do it the proper
way and what you need to do is and do
you know why everybody raised their hand
because as you get older this very scary
thing starts to creep in you don't know
about this [__] yet Max but let me tell
you what it's called it's called
regret and regret is the [__] worst
and so what I want you do for the next
17 years is you live your life without
regret don't blame your parents for
making you go to this or become that do
what the [__] you want on your own two
feet not their paper do it the right way
and do it for a decade and if it doesn't
work out then you can get a [__]
job I thank you so
[Music]
much thank you
[Applause]
Dallas